[Musique]
le film dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui est un film italien qui
s'appelle la vie est belle et qui a été
réalisé en 1997 par Roberto Benigni
alors ce film est un film où il y a
beaucoup d'émotions moi je suis
quelqu'un qui n'est pas trop émotif
habituellement mais à chaque fois que je
regarde ça me donne les larmes aux yeux
alors pour raconter un peu l'histoire du
film ça se passe pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en Italie et c'est
l'histoire d'un père et de son fils qui
vont se voir déporter dans un camp de
concentration et tout au long du film le
père va faire croire à son fils que
c'est un jeu qui a des différentes
épreuves et qui a une récompense à la
fin tout ça pour lui mentir et bien sûr
qu'il ne s'aperçoivent pas de la de la
véracité des faits
donc c'est un film qui a rencontré un
grand succès lors de sa sortie en salle
car il a par la suite obtenu différents
prix notamment un Oscar trois Césars et
un prix du Jury à Cannes c'est un film
que je vous conseille vraiment de
regarder il y a une scène qui est
vraiment touchante vers la fin du film
c'est quand le papa se fait arrêter par
un soldat allemand dans le camp de
concentration
et son fils lui est caché et le voit et
jusqu'au bout le père cache l'effet et
il fait semblant de enfin il fait
l'imbécile pour que son fils ne
s'inquiète pas voilà donc allez le voir
c'est vraiment très intéressant comme
film
[Musique]